-Our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated actress
and comedian you know
from shows such as "Barry,"
"The Good Place"
and "A League of Their Own."
She stars in "Shotgun Wedding,"
which is streaming now
on Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-Peek-a-boo.
-Oh.
-Hi.
[ Smooching ]
Oh, Darcy, I am so honored
to bare witness to this sacred
observance of rebirth
and devotion.
-Same.
-Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
Renata.
♪♪
-I need to go
to the ladies room.
-Please welcome back to the
show, our friend
D'Arcy Carden, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thanks for having me.
-It's very lovely
to have you here.
it's very lovely to have
you back in New York City.
You lived here for a long time.
-I did.
-Now you and your husband
live in L.A.,
and now you're both back.
Are you going to enjoy
your time here?
-We are. We're going to stay
here for a few extra days.
-Okay.
-We're going to see some shows.
I'm really excited about
seeing any old musical.
-Are you pro musical?
-I'm way pro musical.
-How is your husband, Jason,
with musicals?
-Less.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-But that's okay.
-He's a very supportive husband.
He goes to them?
-Yeah, he'll do it. He'll do it.
He wants to see something where,
like, our souls are ripped out
and we're like crying
and we learn something.
-Oh, yeah. Boo.
-I know, it's boring.
-Go learn something
on your own time.
-That's what I say
from the audience.
[ Laughter ]
And they're like,
"Get out of here.
-This is very exciting,
you filmed season 4 of "Barry,"
which is a show
I love a great deal.
-Yeah.
-And obviously, close to a lot
of people in this cast,
gotten to know
Henry Winkler a little bit.
And I'm happy to say my
interactions with him,
he does come off as the nicest
human being in the world.
-It's really genuine.
-You worked with him even more.
-Yeah.
-Have you seen this
to be the case.
-I have seen this
-Okay.
-He's like -- he's like
the best person in the world.
An example would be
I ran into him
and his lovely wife Stacey
recently,
and I was complaining to them
that my husband --
we just talked About him --
-Yeah.
This is a very big segment
for him so far.
[ Laughter ]
-He was going out of town,
and I was going to be
so scared to be in our house
by myself.
And they both were like,
"Well, you'll stay with us.
You'll stay -- you will stay
with us.
You'll in our extra room and you
will stay with us.
And what you're going to do
is stay with us."
It was like there was no --
there was no conversation.
-Did you hesitate?
-I was like, oh,
they're going to say it
and they don't mean it.
There was follow-up texts.
♪ It was the best weekend
of my life ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Were they great hosts?
-The best hosts!
-Oh, my God.
-I had my own room.
They had a little toothbrush,
little like face wash.
Henry had, like, put on the
right channel,
like on the TV,
a music channel.
They are the best.
I mean, like,
Henry made me breakfast.
I'm not kidding.
They're the best people
in the world.
I love them.
They're dear to me.
-It would have been such a
bummer if they had
murdered you, just because.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I guess you're right.
-'Cause a lot of those things
are also what people
that would murder you would do.
Like, they'd put out the
toothbrush to put you at ease.
-Totally.
-You're like, if you were going
to murder me you wouldn't
put out a toothbrush.
-He would never put out
a toothbrush.
And then,
in the middle of the night,
just absolute murder.
-Yeah.
-No, it was the best.
-They're like, "Are your teeth
nice and clean?"
-"They have to be clean."
[ Laughter ]
This is a fantastic cast.
We only saw a couple of people
from the clip,
but a lot of you who filmed
this movie, "Shotgun Wedding,"
got to live together
in a beautiful resort home?
-I know. We keep saying home,
but it is the most --
it's like a, you know,
17-room house.
It is a mansion on the beach.
-Yeah.
-That is a wonderful, kind of,
job to get in show business.
-It's almost not a job.
-Yeah.
And so, you got to live
with, like, Cheech Marin.
-Yep.
-Who was in that clip.
-Yeah, that I kissed.
-Yeah, you kissed Cheech Marin
multiple times
in that clip alone.
I can only imagine how much more
kissing happens
in the rest of the movie.
-You gotta check it out.
I literally never do it again.
-And also, Jennifer Coolidge,
who I guess only does
resort work now.
[ Laughter ]
-She's a smart woman.
-She's a very smart woman.
-She's like, vacation, get paid.
-I thrive in that environment.
-I know.
How was -- what was your
first meeting
with Jennifer Coolidge like?
-Oh, God.
It was great, actually.
She -- I was eating breakfast
at the hotel
before we moved
to the big mansion.
I was eating breakfast
at the hotel and I see her
come in and sit down, and I was
so excited to see her.
And she, at one point, turns
around and she looks at me
and she goes, "Hey, I know you."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Hi."
And she's like,
"We just worked together."
And I was like, "No.
No, we didn't --
no, we didn't work together."
And she's like, "Yeah, yeah.
we just worked together, right?"
And I was like, "Jennifer,
I don't know how to say this,
if we worked together,
I would know because
I'm obsessed with you.
I love you," and she got it.
-Yeah.
-She's like, "Oh, yeah."
-It's funny.
I've had that a few times
where people who
are way more famous than me...
-I know, I know.
-...insist we met before,
and I have to be like,
"Don't take this the wrong way,
I'd [bleep] remember."
Yeah.
-That's it.
-Yeah.
You're like, you can't --
you have to just say it bluntly.
You're like, "Trust me!
I would have told
my family about this."
-Yeah.
-I have more to ask you
about the film.
We'll be right back with
our friend, D'Arcy Carden.
[ Cheers and applause ]